(restless music)
- [Voiceover] This is a
Japanese giant salamander.
It is massive.
This primeval amphibian can grow up to
five feet long and weigh over 50 pounds,
making it one of the largest salamanders
to ever crawl the face of the Earth.
Despite it's primitive look,
the Japanese giant
salamander is highly evolved.
It is covered head to tail
with specialized cells
that detect tiny vibrations
in its environment.
When it detects a threat, it excretes
a strong-smelling ooze that
smells like a Japanese pepper,
hence, its common Japanese
name, giant pepper fish.
The Japanese giant salamander
is entirely aquatic,
and spends its life in
clear, cool flowing streams.
It has no gills, but instead
absorbs oxygen through its skin.
If left alone, the
Japanese giant salamander
will live a long life.
This one is 26 years old, and in the wild
they can live to be nearly 80.
But pollution of its river
habitat, and over collection,
are threatening this
fascinating primordial creature.
This is the Japanese giant salamander.
(restless music)